hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i've been
investing in property now for 12 years
i've done hundreds of deals but this
is not about me this is not about the
fact that i own a 20-bedroom castle this
is not about the fact that my net worth
is 20 million pounds today
this is about you as a samuel leeds
subscriber now if you are not already a
subscriber then please what are you
waiting for smash the like and subscribe
all the buttons that you can press that
would help this video subscribe
notification bell on like why not just
do it man i mean honestly
you won't lose anything you own the game
it doesn't cost money to like a video
it's like you may as well just hit the
like button what's this video about this
video is about you and your questions so
if you've got any questions around
business
any problem that you might be facing
guess what someone
has come across that same problem and
probably i have so if you've got a
problem a challenge
comment below
let's see if i can help you out let's
see what questions we had from last week
jack hale said
i'm a rookie and i'm really new to the
property game so if i buy a house with
cash get finance
and add value to the property then i get
it revalued do i take my cash i put in
plus the value that's been adding in
and give the finance back to the lender
plus the lender's premium on top
yes
yes you do
next question
jack
you buy a house for 100 grand
you spend 50 grand on that house
but you've now pushed the value up to
200 000
let's say you borrowed all of the money
initially to put into that house let's
say you use private finance
bridging
angel investment whatever so you buy a
house for a hundred grand you spend 50
doing it up you've put none of your own
money in
if the new value is 200
you're then going to take out a buy to
let mortgage
they're going to give you 150 grand
you're going to use that 150 grand to
pay back all of the money and you're
left with a free
house so that's exactly how it works and
that strategy is called b-r-r
by refurbish refinance and i've been
doing that for many years and serve
loads of my students
all right n bambi
currently reading your book which i'm
finding very informative thank you
regarding multi-let's what do you do if
you let out a three-bedroom property to
three individuals
but one
has their partner over most
if not all nights and disturbs the other
tenets
effectively becoming the fourth
unpaid tenant how would you avoid
free
loaders like this
um and bambi this happens all the time
so let's say you've got yeah a property
a three bed um normally what i do is i
will
rent one of the rooms out specifically
in mind that it's to a couple because
you're gonna get more rent for a couple
so you should be getting a maybe extra
hundred pound a month for a couple so if
the room is 400 but you want to move two
people into the room you can't charge
two lots of rent because they're only
renting
one room right they're not renting two
rooms but you can charge a little bit
extra because they're obviously taking
up more um you know gas and electric and
things like that i wouldn't worry about
it too much though like people do people
do my attitude generally speaking is if
there's someone in a bedroom and they're
getting sleepovers and they're getting a
girlfriend and the girlfriend kind of is
in there all the time in the contract it
will specifically say that they can't
have someone in the property more than
three nights a week
if they are it doesn't really affect me
i'm not in the house so i'm not gonna be
trying to catch them out and getting
losing sleep over it i'm just gonna
think
if they start getting complaints that's
a different story if the other tenants
start getting annoyed hey they have the
girlfriend in there then i might get a
letter sent out just to say look we've
been advised that you've got someone but
i wouldn't lose sleep over it um i
definitely think that
i definitely think it's a valid question
but i wouldn't worry your cotton little
socks my darling
hi owen henderson
just wondering if you could give some
advice on finding a co-deal saucer i can
work with until i get my company up and
running
uh owen henderson i'm loving the
questions today you guys are amazing
honestly i love doing this owen
henderson kodial sourcing is a really
good strategy for anyone that doesn't
know what that's what he's talking about
so owen owen henderson
right now is finding property deals
owen henderson
thinks that these deals are so good
that he deserves to be paid he deserves
an investor to come along buy these
deals that he's found and give him a fee
problem he probably doesn't know any
investors problem he doesn't even have a
company no insurance
no limited liability protection
nothing so he's like i've got these
deals but what can i do so my advice
owen i think getting the kodi or sauce
it makes sense
this is where
you find a deal saucer that's already up
and running that's packaging and selling
deals already and you say to them hey
what do you think of this deal
best way to do this owen rather than
finding a deal and then trying to pitch
that deal to codial sources
and they're going to be like oh
go on what you got and then you're
desperate to sell the deal so they'll
call the shots
best thing to do is approach deal
sources with no deal
ask them what their investors are
looking for
and then they'll be all my investors are
looking for brr hmos in the northwest or
whatever and then say if i can find
something like that
would you potentially be open to doing a
deal whether i could find it you could
sell it and we could do a commission
split
how do you find those people uh they're
everywhere i mean dude just go on my
facebook group where there's over 30 000
members there's so many deal sources
there however if you haven't had any
training or any experience in the
industry they might not want to work
with you because they might just think
oh man this person is just a nobody and
trying to suck us of all our information
and believe our systems and take out
this and take our investors so
best bet is a lot of deal sources will
ask you have you been trained my advice
get on samuel leaves training learn how
to package and sell deals and then once
you've got the knowledge and experience
then go and start approaching deal
sources and then because you've had the
training and you've got the confidence
and they you they'll you'll be a breeze
to work with and everyone will want to
work with you
last question if you've got a question
comment below and i will do my very best
to answer your question next time but
last question for now is razvan gabriel
razvan gabriel says i'm planning to buy
my first house in manchester and i want
to get a lodger in
do all lenders except this
or is this something that needs to be
agreed before signing the papers
is there anything else that i need to
consider for this to work thanks in
advance razvan gabriel razvan
okay so nearly every lender will let you
do this you won't need any letter or any
permission um there are
one or two lenders that might prohibit
you from doing this but nearly all
lenders will be fine with you having a
lodger in the house
on a normal residential mortgage on the
condition that you're living there if
you move out
and rent the rooms out you'll need
permission but if you're living there
and you've got a spare room you should
be fine
um
check obviously check your terms and
conditions with your lender but
nine times out of ten you'll be fine um
anything you need to consider well yes
of course there is firstly you need to
consider the advantages of doing this
from a tax point of view see let's say
you've got a room in your house and you
rent out for
500 pound a month
that's going to give you
500 that's going to give you what six
six grand six grand a year
you will pay
zero tax
on that six thousand pounds
that's amazing it's called bedroom
relief tax you don't pay any tax up
until your first seven and a half
thousand pounds which is amazing so
tax wise it's a brilliant idea all of
the money that you get you're paying no
tax on it which is great um i'd
obviously make sure if you're having
someone live in your house in your spare
room as a lodger you need to make sure
that you have the lodges agreement
don't just move them in and have no
agreement because then if they stop
paying their rent or whatever you're
going to struggle to get them out make
sure you have an agreement make sure you
move somebody in that seems like a nice
reasonable person um
get references off them and everything
because if they're a tenant get a
largest agreement boom shakalaka go for
it let me know what happens when you get
your logic
guys if you enjoyed this video hit the
like button if you've got questions for
me hit them down below and i'll do my
best to answer every single question
next week look forward to speaking to
you soon god bless peace out